welcome to this video and not bored at
oriel laboratorium wow I'm Bo two or
three whenever that happens i feel like
i urgently need to win a game what did i
do it it s course so poorly the last
couple of games probably I did okay yeah
this d3 line that some currently quite
fashionable I mean it's vegetable for
quite a while now but some trend of the
last couple of years okay I think before
is played
okay probably just see five sometimes
you can play b3 this kind of pawn
sacrifice but didn't look like a
position of that type okay very complex
typical typically complex real middle
game where not only five isn't some it's
an important piece it looks strange on a
five but sometimes it plays a very
useful role in jumping to be three I'm
trying to prepare that he's kind of
suffering a bit him I mean suffering I'm
not implying what is worse worse he is
not but he has to worry about 93 and and
those kind of those kind of operations
um c 4 move him sure why not him that
looks kind kind of good make some his
bishop look bit bad on d2 and
threatening to take and here i have nite
nite b3 right which should be quite nice
I mean he has to take it now otherwise I
take Bishop f4
yeah so how do i check it but both it's
both looking good taking it with the
pawn this is a more aggressive way pawn
takes probably Queen between yes to
probably block with the Queen that looks
really bad but I'd like I need a night
on Sofia that would kind of win the game
maybe maybe I can get this end bishop
here 97 b6 this kind of business or
queen sometimes Quincy form hmm okay
nothing for mood do I have some chance
to get a night them if I play Bishop
g-form how I see where is he putting the
night somewhere and I am I don't know
okay let's play that not not coming to
big time travel here from this position
look a three by the way is a move that I
should have paid some attention to hmm
yeah okay that's that's a move but I
thought I have 25 Yakima if that's
possible it should be good right
just opening opening everything here for
for the bishops and whites pieces look
kind of scattered if he takes on e5 I
thought Knight takes e4 is the move and
yeah at ed 5 i'm probably taking on
default first ok that's not happening if
i take on deform he is playing what we
should f4 but then i take on c3 yeah
this looks remarkably bad
ok I'm going to take that we should
therefore I cannot believe we should be
a 4 tick on c3
was that too too lazy here not
calculating this in any in any detail
Bishop f4 so ok it's not doing that here
I can just play night if all right all
right if I can take that I can take here
first right yep and 94 I guess ok
night night coming to d5 or possibly e6
now e6 I can take the night so that's
not working but 95 this is an annoying
move so when you cover that simply I
would really like to put the bishop on
your six to keep the pawn here maybe
maybe this one I like a little bit of
time to really fully um calculate this
if he takes on e4 with the rook do I
have do I have some good move
John Bishop f5 looks like a problem
doesn't doesn't don't see a square where
you can go to okay night possibly coming
to them but ok let's send for Hackett
play with d3 not sure where this Bishop
is now going shouldn't be a really good
square
okay oops didn't see that at all
hm did I look some technical when I'm
pretty sure I did still looks highly
highly critical of course with the beep
on sobe to
check
check yeah okay so I I really did win
like there's no but hell kind of shaky
somewhere around here on a little bit
later were you thinking okay it should
really fall apart completely this
position porn chicks take so let's see
him this move okay at least okay look
III wasn't it a bit best defense yeah
given by the comp which is minus 0.5
this kind of thing but he here at least
gets the pawn on b3 but he went here and
now I plead the fif which looks not to
call admittedly compounds to play night
h5 that looks that looks strange but ok
it threatens 93 Bishop e2 winning it
gives black a winning positions anyway
but ok d5 but it seems d5 also seems to
be going here takes with the pawn okay
the comp actually wants to take with a
night and gives this as even better with
them this kind of line intending f6 the
night does not have many squares it's
very strong but okay did I what did I do
Quincy force stronger but that is still
a complete win so why did I swear did I
screw up minus three yeah maybe I didn't
screw up and I just underestimated the
whole thing okay I took group 23 it's
all minus 3 and stuff look at the eight
strong now okay just for deadly pin but
okay what I did is always minus 3 minus
4 minus five so I didn't really make a
big mistake but Jim job I wasn't it
wasn't sure how good it really is it
looked excellent but it can easily
happen that you make some kind of stupid
mistake and then you beep on it suddenly
gone or something so um I was the kind
of kind of cautious of this really
really we know we can some more struggle
on I wonder where exactly did the
opening go wrong for wide if we go this
is this of course this is normal this is
completely theory maybe maybe this is
somehow miss time maybe I don't know I
mean 11 ideas for white in general is to
play this kind of thing when Knight to
c4 it's debatable because this is this
on this dallin sizzix doesn't look
really great but sometimes as we have
seen it does have a function I really
got to be three with good effect maybe
this is really wrong yeah I can place
your form could have done so one move
earlier even let him yeah he it's clear
that already something has gone wrong
the problem is that well we saw that d4
Knight b3 is excellent and what exactly
is White's move I mean computer wants to
do this and here I can play and I can
also take me at leave at this is this is
also a good move this leads to the
structure this is a relatively best that
white can get and this is kind of kind
of poor with those with those big pawns
so this is kind of the dream position
that you want and they're in the closed
away with black better structure and
white has no no activity on the kingside
one or anything yeah so you probably has
to
improve on this Bishop d to move Jeff I
mean rookie 192 those kind of moves
should be should be ok ok thanks for
watching